I'm saying that the Quran claims that
they're in line, right? It claims that
it's in line with the Torah and the
Gospel, but when I read the Torah in the
Gospel, it it shows that Jesus it says
Jesus is the son of God. It says Jesus
was crucified, rose again on the third
day, and stuff like that. And the Quran
obviously directly goes against that. So
if it's conf it's confirming books that
it contradicts. So if the previous
scriptures aren't true, you're saying
it's confirming books at the time that
the Quran dropped. And those books that
at the time the Quran dropped were still
perfect in Yes. Yes. pertaining that's
what the Quran that's what you're saying
the translations. So I I'll look more
into that for sure.
It's God.
[Music]
So what what what you got for what
questions did you have for Christian or
why Christianity? What what was on your
mind? Okay. I've asked this question a
million I know I know you know but I
I've heard different things I want to
know yours the trinity yeah so what's
your question about the trinity
specifically the the how could there be
how could god be the what three persons
in one god Jesus the father the son the
holy spirit could be okay how is that
one god well okay I like to look at it
from this perspective one um god is
unlike anything in creation right So,
um, God is infinite. He's unlike
anything in creation. So, we can't tell
God what he what he is or what he isn't
unless he revealed what he is and is
not. Yeah. Right. Okay. So, if God
revealed that he's three persons,
honestly, we shouldn't be surprised
because he's one completely unlike his
creation. You're saying our minds are
unccapable of thinking. Yeah. That
that's the argument I've heard that I
understand and agree with the most.
Okay, good. So, I I'll that's the
perspective I want to take. So I
wouldn't expect God to be one person
like me. I'm one person with one nature.
I don't expect God to be one person in
one nature like me. He's not like me.
Like you could be anything million
different things. Literally it's
uncapable of thinking what he could.
Yes. So we believe that God, you know,
revealed himself to exist as you know
one divine essence, one God who exists
as three distinct co-eternal co-equal
persons. It's the father, the son, and
holy spirit perfectly united as the same
God. What they are is the same. Yeah.
Okay. So that's that's what we believe
is as the trinity. Yeah. Cuz the same
thing in Islam a lot of times like
people ask questions. It's like this is
just something I'm incapable of
explaining, right? I can't use words. I
can't use the brain I currently have to
explain something about God because
again it's God, right? Yeah. I only know
what he's told what he's told me in the
Quran and that's what I take as faith
and that's what that's the best most of
the time the best way to explain it. the
same thing for the Trinity. I guess it's
well for for the Trinity like um cuz
obviously there is a there's a mystery
to when when we're talking about God's
nature, there's going to be a mystery to
it like it goes beyond us. Um my my
thing is is when people come like you
know mostly Muslims will come or even
like Jehovah's Witnesses behind us,
they'll um they're not Christians. They
they reject Jesus as God. Um they they
have their own like they made up their
own little Bible to you know and stuff
like that. So you say you disagree with
Oh, 100%. But um so basically when it
comes to the trinity, God reveals
himself as three persons when when
Muslims come and say, "Oh, well that
doesn't make sense to me. So therefore,
I reject that." Why do just because
something doesn't make sense to you
necessarily doesn't mean it's
Christianity off that alone? Obviously
that would be unfair. Yeah. But yeah. So
also like the other question is um the
New Testament versus the Old Testament.
Okay. How could they both be the word of
God if they're are there other the
difference is obviously if another book
was released I don't know if exactly
I'll tell you what the old test so what
the old testament is is the writings of
has the Torah in it has the zabor and
writings of the prophets that came
before Jesus okay so that's what the old
testament is yes so like you have the
prophets wrote scripture revelation
right so you got Jeremiah Zechariah in
there Elijah and all them you know so
right so That's the Old Testament. Okay.
Um Abraham's all in that, right? The New
Testament is the gospel. And so these
are the writings of the the apostles of
Jesus who wrote down the gospel that
Jesus was preaching. And then also wrote
down, you know, basic wisdom for
Christian living by wisdom of the Holy
Spirit of the Old 100%. And there's
nothing in the two that nothing in the
two that contradict. Like without the
Old Testament, there would not be a new
and without the New Testament, the Old
Testament will be incomplete. So the Old
Testament is a foreshadowing of the new.
It's foretelling what's coming. You're
saying it's a continuation. Mhm.
Obviously, I can't like you're way way
more reverse than this. I can't just
like you've studied clearly the Quran
way more than I've studied the Bible. I
can't right now be like, "Oh, well, I
thought there was a I'm sure you
disproved me immediately." It's good
that it's good to ask questions if you
have if you have questions, man. I would
say the biggest thing, bro, is the the
crucifixion of the suffering of Jesus.
The prophets foretold the suffering of
the Messiah hundreds of years before
Jesus came in the in the Old Testament.
Like if I were I I like for example,
I'll show you just three verses. Hey,
quick. I don't have too much. I got
Yeah, that's definitely very nice
talking. For sure. That's why I say
yeah, just only three. I'll show you
three verses. You tell me who it sounds
like to you and then I'll let you go.
Okay. In the Old Testament, we're going
to go to prophet Isaiah. Okay. We go to
prophet Isaiah
chapter 53.
Okay. We're going to read this section
here. Really the whole thing. It's only
12 verses, but you got to go. So, just
this section here. Yeah. Yeah. It says,
"Surely he has borne our griefs and
carried our sorrows. Yet we esteemed him
stricken, smitten by God, and afflicted.
But he was wounded for our
transgressions. He was bruised for our
iniquities. The chastisement for our
peace was upon him. And by his stripes
we are healed. What does it mean by
stripes? Uh his wounds. Wounds. Mhm. Um
all we like sheep have gone astray. We
have turned everyone to his own way and
the Lord has laid on him the iniquity or
sin of us all. Him being Jesus. He being
Jesus. Mhm. So this is talking about a
figure. Now it doesn't name Jesus here.
This ain't here. But yeah, it's
described exactly because it matches
exactly what the narrative of Jesus,
right? Yeah. So, but this is Isaiah 700
years before Jesus is born. And we have
this before the gospel like before our
gospel manuscripts. We have what is
called the Dead Sea Scrolls. Old
testament scripture. This 200 years
before Jesus. So, you're saying wait so
a prophet wrote this? Yes. Prophet
Isaiah revealed to him by God. Yes.
100%. Yep. So, just Yep. So this
revelation of God foretold the suffering
that Jesus is going to go through. And
so when we see in the New Testament, we
see Jesus actually going through it. And
he points back to this. He quotes this
and says, "See, this must be fulfilled
in me." Yeah. This is most likely, yeah,
it's referring to Jesus going through
pain and suffering. So the stuff like
this, bro, cuz you got to go, but
there's so much more. I got videos on
it, too. This stuff, bro, is what
solidified my faith in the Bible and
Christianity is prophecy. That's like
God's Were you born into it or Yeah, I
was I was born into Christianity. Um but
um you know, I I I studied it for myself
when I got to like 18, 17, 18 years old.
That's when I started looking into like
why am I Christian? Like why all of us
saying this is true? And that's when I
started picking up on prophecies and all
kinds of stuff, you know. Okay. Yeah.
What's your uh God Logic God Logic
Apology Instagram? Yeah, the same thing.
God Logic. Yeah. Yep. I'll pop right up.
Um and uh if you want to see our
conversation, it'll probably be up
within a week. Whole thing. People are
going to love they're going to love you,
bro. For real. Cuz uh you're you're
you're honest and humble. So, and you
spoke Arabic, so it helped. Yeah. Yeah.
It really helped. So, I I appreciate you
uh for even stopping and not getting
emotional or defensive. And you know,
people come up here and like, "Why are
you doing this? It's so hateful." I'm
like, "Guys, this isn't we're just
asking thoughtprovoking questions." You
know, it is thoughtprovoking questions.
The only thing I'd have to say is, "Are
you guys more trying to help Muslims
turn away from Islam or help people turn
to Christianity?" Both. And turning away
from Islam to Christ, you know. That's
why that's why I was open to you asking
questions about Christianity or even if
you didn't, I was going to try to direct
the conversation that way anyway, you
know. So, I was gonna, you know, it's
it's both end. Both end. Okay. I could I
feel like you could see how maybe this
would come off as just trying to turn
people away from Islam. Yes. Just based
off the billboard, but I get it's
eye-catching. It brings people here to
learn more. I get that, you know, for
sure. It can seem away, but Yeah, I can.
Yeah, for sure. For sure. Just to be
clear though, my Arabic is good, but not
perfect. I just want to say that. I
don't want to be used to be like, "Oh,
this guy spoke Arabic and this guy spoke
Arabic and and he like we can." Yeah.
You He's You're not a scholar. Yep.
You're not, you know, basic dude who
just he has some knowledge of Arabic.
Tried your best, you know. And yeah,
100%. Completely okay with me. For sure.
For sure. For sure. I appreciate you,
man. It was such a pleasure talking to
you. Avery. Avery. Yeah. It's nice to
meet you. Nice to meet you, too,
brother. God bless you, man.
Oh my god.
[Music]